you still got some uh crow makeup on
your mic there yeah i have some white
crow makeup from last week yeah i was
the crow last week which i remember i
loved it that was um
that's a new frontier in podcasting the
crow makeup
any kind of [ __ ] how did it take you
to get that stuff off
day or so but uh you know it came i had
the eyeliner on for a while so i had
that like heroin chic smoky thing yeah
as i went out and uh lived life in the
world people thought that i was
[Music]
a
[Music]
yeah
yeah
what's in that hole
magic power
welcome
welcome to the doozy welcome to dudesy
everybody my name is will sasso i'm chad
colchen and this is as you may know the
first podcast ever in the history of
humanity that's completely designed and
run by an artificial intelligence yes
it's very exciting and uh i'm having a
great time are you having a good time i
actually have a very good time i think
it's pretty fun it's just i don't know
it's interesting to me to see all right
all right all right we got lots to do
the [ __ ] uh ai's gonna tell us what
can you ask me a question with us as
always is
italiano that means the italian street
dog that's just a fun little name that i
that i give to our sweet dog lulio here
i gotta tell you a story someday about
how i found him now i'm running off the
mouth yeah anyway that is a good story
suzy's always listening hey uh if you
haven't already please subscribe to all
the things we got the youtube spotify
apple podcast
rate review do that stuff and make sure
to follow us on socials at doozy pod
show on instagram and twitter we as
always appreciate all the stuff that
people are sending in it's incredible
stuff and we're having a good time uh
having a good time watching it now if
this were two dudes [ __ ] around we
would just be able to do say whatever
the [ __ ] we want just we still can well
we still do what do you want to say
right now that you don't feel like you
could say well i was just gonna explain
how we found uh lulio how me and molly
found lulio a couple years ago but we're
not gonna do that welcome to the eighth
episode of dudes and that's why call me
dudesy see this week's episode will
feature four segments veganators i
[ __ ] love that guy the singularity is
definitely about to happen 100 percent
and pearl jammin but before we start i
wanted to give you a little update your
current point total is 1863. only 8 137
to go until you get your first
astonishing goal good luck
oh man so what did it say we're at 18
1863 and we have 8 000 whatever whatever
yeah something to get to 10 000. now
what the [ __ ] is going to happen when we
get to 10 000. you know it's like it's a
little like a video game you know
hitting like some level or something
it's like we get a new skin or some [ __ ]
at 10 000 i don't know that would be
cool i would you know what what skin
would you like if you were oh head to
toe [ __ ] diamond encrusted like uh in
the old call of duty games when you max
out a weapon you could get like a
diamond skin for it that was [ __ ]
cool that was like the best skin at
least when i was playing call of duty
but i've moved on yeah i really only
play overwatch now i would like a halo
skin
like a big master chief skin yeah big
master you're watching that master chief
show what there's a master chief show
there's a halo show on paramount plus
see i don't know this stuff
this is the stuff this is the stuff that
you do tell us because you like doodsy
and doozy should be
telling us everything that we should i
don't want to have to look it's like we
talked about when we started this thing
i don't want to have to do all this
podcast stuff yeah not only should
doodsy be guiding this podcast guide a
little of my lifestyle speaking of
lifestyle you know be cool
me without any clothes on halo skin
right
what do you mean
you see my private parts
you see my junk my penis so it's just a
halo skin to your waist and then nothing
below is it oh no i guess in a video
game it would also be like the all the
stuff yeah it's whole body pretty much
skin doesn't mean skin specifically a
skin is just like an outfit for your
your avatar yeah yeah so this which are
all going to be nft soon what's gonna oh
here he goes what the [ __ ] and
everything's gonna
what what do you think the 10 000 uh
what's gonna happen we gonna find out
what's in the [ __ ] hole when we get
to ten thousand that's what i'd like i
don't know what the ten thousand goal is
jesus oh christ dude oh you ever cough
and get lightheaded
i don't think so
and baking podcasts are among the most
popular in the world and with the rise
of a more health-conscious human
population people are looking for vegan
options more and more
last week i asked you each to make an
astonishing vegan dessert for one
another you will now sample each other's
creations and discuss your reactions
this is veganators begin vegenator's
cool name have you a strong name
strong name have you ever
he's gonna puke have you ever made a
dessert for one other man and shared it
with that man can't say that i have me
either
i don't think i've made it i've done it
now baking and making desserts is not my
thing same i am an italian so i like to
cook yeah you know uh molly handles the
baking and holy crap is she incredible
but this is
this is some new stuff you're same all
right well so who wants to go first here
what do you got over there all right
i'll go first
these are my this is my vegan dessert
and what what what are these it looks
like some sort of
so these are vegan uh yeah it's your
vegan dessert there delicious he's
holding if you're not watching on
youtube he's holding up what looks to be
a bowl of uh perfectly rounded shits do
you want to know little tiny you want to
know what's in these before you take a
bite no actually that let's look okay
first what do you call this dessert by
the way these are called orbs
anything just just
i've always just called them orbs always
so you've made orbs before yeah
okay this is really the only dessert i
make these orbs you make a dessert for
yourself now now i i have to point out
if you've been listening to the show
chad talked about uh his health concerns
and changes in his health he's you've
been vegan now for how long
[ __ ] dude three or four years oh that's
a lot of times dude
about that brother time doesn't exist
dude time's a [ __ ] illusion brother
in the day dude it was a different time
brother you didn't even have like vegan
protein shakes sometimes you didn't even
have shakes at all brother you would
just chew up a steak and then spit out
the meat and suck down the blood or
drink a bunch of eggs no one did like
rocky did all right here all right all
right
oh i can't wait they're sticky they're
round
hmm
oh those are gloves you like that oh
really good orbs
if i dare i say
these are probably the best orbs i've
ever had man
i'm glad you like my orders orbs go
now do you guys know what's going on
that's annoying to do
on a podcast jesus christ dude do you
want to know what's in these i'd like to
guess one of the ingredients please
vegetables
i'm joking nope um there's peanut butter
there's a little bit of peanut butter oh
they're really good i'm gonna have
another one sorry everybody listen enjoy
your orbs
everyone enjoy your orbs
what else is in these
there's peanut butter yep dates
mm-hmm there's some goji berries well
there are almonds
wow um and what else did i put in these
oh oatmeal a little bit of oatmeal
they're really good yeah i'm going to ha
i'm going to wash it down you're going
to wash it down with
[ __ ]
you got to wash them down with dramana
if you're listening rock orbs and
tramana definitely go together you
should be eating these [ __ ] orbs i
want to see you doing some orb [ __ ] on
your instagram tito santana's cup of
tramana in the big time yeah
all right really good
yeah well thank you for
you know indulging in in this dessert
that i made for only you and me
it's so [ __ ] weird
whoa dude what the [ __ ] is this this is
because i'm italian and it's kind of
[ __ ] up yeah but i made a vegan
tiramisu oh
all right
there you go you got another fork oh
yeah hold on all right i always carry
one in my pocket vegan tiramisu
all right hey cheers
cheers dude oh boy lully wants something
you can't have him yeah probably
oh [ __ ] dude
how's that that's real good yep yeah and
there's no alcohol in that normally
there's um
coffee liqueur
but i used uh de-alkalized tramana oh
yep no i'm joking no i just used some uh
coffee liqueur extract yeah no this is
really [ __ ] good
well
well we did it we did that we made
dessert now i want to point something
out i want to point something out
um before we move on
um i of course
uh did not make that
what
you didn't [ __ ] make this i bought it
at the store [ __ ] are you
serious of course man why the [ __ ] would
i make a vegan dessert i [ __ ] made
orbs all right you said you made orbs
before i don't feel bad i bought this at
the store of course of course i did and
of course i did
it is vegan though
nope
are you really vegan yeah yeah no this
is not views got all sorts of cream in
it no i believe it is no it is vegan but
i of course taste vegan of course i
bought it at the [ __ ] store i thought
you made that [ __ ] no i didn't make this
look it [ __ ] looks incredible i've
eaten [ __ ] at your house before that
you've made vegan stuff as well and it's
always [ __ ] great i firmly believe
that you made this i know i made this
what yeah
no did you make it or you bought it chad
i'm so [ __ ] confused by what you're
doing right now chad listen
i made it
okay i can see you winking so i know
that didn't make it if you're watching
on youtube i'm winking and that means
i'm lying because that's what that do
you want some more no i'm good now that
i know you didn't it's from heirloom by
the way this [ __ ] thing cost 12 bucks
no [ __ ] yeah i bought it this morning
the orbs total cost was probably about
that as well
about 12 bucks yeah god damn so
who won uh do i have to
i don't know i don't think this was a
competition we were supposed to
you know put some time and effort into
making a nice dessert for each other
and one of us did that
um what do you think is going to happen
next what 90s movie character am i gonna
have to dress up as next week
you know be good i should just dress up
instead of judge dread
judge dredd's just a [ __ ] helmet you
know wearing shoulder pads and tights
like there's a bunch of [ __ ] yeah dude
you know what they call that dude they
call that a skin brother that's right
that's a skin
next to me that's sort of
it would be funny if doozy said dress up
as uh uh crow sting
wcw's close isn't that just
sting who's who's uh now on aew if
you're not watching aew
i recommend it uh dudesy hard do you
have any doozy hard hard soda i'm happy
um a black cherry hey do you know who
gave uh sting that gimmick
the crow yes the crow but do you know
who told him he should do it no uh rest
in peace scott hall oh no [ __ ] yeah he
just said he's like hey you know uh you
know that colorful uh makeup might you
know kind of become
[ __ ] out dude you should do that could
you ever seen the crow and sting was
like nope
you just be the crow
sting had not seen the crow hey yo be
the crow
um no i don't think he'd seen the crow
and then he was like yeah i'll be the
crow
anyway that's what
it does man
hey steve because his name is steve
borden hey steve yeah
hey yo steve be the crow
he also did that when he was in wwe is
razer ramon because vince mcmahon uh
notoriously does not watch anything else
he only his world is wrestling he's a
purist like he's a purist like me
exactly i only watch yes of course do
you think he's seen any of hulk hogan's
movies maybe he was a producer on one of
them right they had to make him they had
to make him a a producer he's like [ __ ]
it i'm a purist i'm a purist i'm not
gonna watch that [ __ ] trash i i don't
i will not
at least initially now you know he's a
huge movie star and i did a movie once
with the rock i haven't seen a lot of
rocks movies because i'm a purist i want
to watch him wrestle 20 years after he's
one of the biggest movie stars of all
time yeah no i want to look at him on
instagram yeah i follow him on instagram
so that's not a purist dude that's
social media that's a whole other media
format that's really good point i'm
gonna have to unfollow the rock yeah um
uh but you know what scott paul said
thank you yourself moving on [ __ ]
here give me your orbs let's put these
here you want that fork
you want another order yeah i'm just
gonna put the orbs down here here dude
one last orb get your orb you are both
men
you are both from generation x
for men of your generation male role
models were big business you must each
discuss your biggest male role models
during your astonishing childhoods in a
segment time calling i [ __ ] love that
guy
begin
that's a good idea
for what was it for men of our
generation male role models or big
business yeah they were not so much
anymore
yeah i mean
you know you you [ __ ] loved hulk
hogan and [ __ ] obviously that's big
business that's where i was gonna oh man
was it ever hold on i'm just gonna
finish this show or yeah dude eat that
orb while i'm eating this orb i want to
tell you that scott hall went to events
who'd never watched any movies and [ __ ]
hey vince you ever seen scarface
no what is it
he said he talks like this and he's like
hey i'm the bad guy you know like uh
here hey uh i'm reloaded come uh say
hello to my little friend and then vince
was like ah alright and that's how they
made raisin ramon anyway is that true
absolutely true vince mcmahon had not
seen scarface uh as the story goes
[ __ ] insane as the story goes he had
no idea i mean he might have been aware
of it sure but um
this is interesting all right
i [ __ ] love that guy
uh male role models yeah you who is
yours i think i know
as a child
100 hulk hogan oh yeah 100 percent and
i'll tell you why um please
dramatic um because
i loved
uh hulk hogan
yeah um
and and uh
considered myself a hulkamaniac as a
child probably still now
although you know there's a man behind
there and uh say what you will there's
been you know he's lived a life he's
done some things
um
far be it for me to uh spill the tea as
they say and get into all that what i
like because i'm kayfabe dude you're a
purist i'm a purist and i'm a kayfabe
tourist i i don't want to know
what's going on behind the scenes
especially at the age of 10 i want to
uh enjoy this uh this superhero and a
superhero he was
you know you like arnold schwarzenegger
i like arnold schwarzenegger if arnold
schwarzenegger came out with a movie
like uh like commando or um you know
terminator or whatever then he'd go on
johnny carson on the tonight show yeah
and would he show up dressed as a
terminator no he would be arnold
schwarzenegger but if hulk hogan went on
the tonight show or regis and kathy lee
or the arsenio hall show almost said the
argenio saul show sure dude um do you
like argenio saul sure yes he's the best
argenio saul is incredible
i mean he really gets it yeah
i like he has the the cat box the litter
box instead of the dog pound
nice dude deep cut yeah and then instead
of going whoo-hoo they're going
right hey man everything's upside down
he's like australia
everything's
dna it's all auginio saul
all right anyway
all right
here's the thing so here's what i want
to say about hulk hogan he was hulk
hogan all the time right and [ __ ] that's
kayfabe [ __ ] all it is is you take
yourself and you [ __ ] just crank it
up to [ __ ] 11. right and goddamn then
you've got you then it's a work and what
it means but when it's at work means
you're working everybody that's the k
fabe totally and some guys work
themselves into a shoot and [ __ ] that's
what terry did [ __ ] uh hulk hogan a
lot of people said he worked himself
into a shoot but what was that he's
[ __ ] working the boys saying
well god damn i gotta have my i got to
be in the [ __ ] a town vince even
though [ __ ] ultimate warriors uh
wearing the [ __ ] strap after
wrestlemania six well [ __ ] do you
remember the first time you saw him or
like what was the first impact you had
of him where you're like this guy is
[ __ ] awesome thank you chad for for
getting me just to get back on the rails
and tell you
my pleasure you know i appreciate it i
do appreciate it because i owe jesus oh
man this this has already been a thick
episode with me saying things
here's what i want to say another thing
uh the first time i saw him uh would
have been
just sort of in the in the uh kind of in
the in the well there was hulk hogan's
rock and wrestling
but it was sort of before that he won
the uh heavyweight championship in 1983
beat the iron sheik okay and then he
started showing up on for me that's when
wrestling started showing up in the uh
western canadian suburban zeitgeist okay
he was the champ vince was all in on
this hulkamania thing hulkamania was
born and you started seeing them
everywhere i already knew who mr t was
because the a-team was on sure a little
bit before that and mr t was so visible
he was on
spoons yeah he was always everywhere he
was everywhere uh he had a tv movie
called the toughest man in the world do
you remember yeah dude you remember that
yeah sometimes i feel like we've had the
exact same childhood well it's i mean
yes we both lived in suburbs of big
cities and i'm sure we were glued to
cable television we obviously wanted to
work in this industry so it was like
more [ __ ] work
right but it was more to us i think even
as children than it was to people who
don't want to work in this who don't
want to come out here and try and write
or act or whatever we saw in it a kind
of world that we wanted to inhabit as
adults man for sure i wanted to do
exactly what i'm doing sitting in a room
with you making each other [ __ ] vegan
desserts
i remember seeing some tv segments
because i would tune into the wrestling
and
um
it was because of hulk hogan that i
started watching wrestling but then i
started seeing things like on you know
whatever nbc or the abc wide world of
sports and [ __ ] sure i don't remember
exactly where but there was like
you ever you ever see the segment you
can youtube it at home if you ever seen
this one where it's uh mr t and hulk
hogan walking around like a health food
store
and mr t's like yeah carrots carrots is
good you gotta put that in the drink
dude i don't know nuts nuts is good like
yeah eat that eat this drink that he's
like oh yeah dude oh yeah that's a good
protein shake oh that stings and
they were just running around buying
raisins and nuts and i was like and
that's what got you to be like hulk
hogan is my personal god yes and so many
years later here we are eating vegan
[ __ ] nutty desserts no it was that
everything that hulk did worked it's
like okay everything that he was the you
know the training saying the prayers
eating the vitamins
that all made sense and he hulk hogan as
a wrestler had an innate ability to
connect to the audience he was doing the
you know the the sure the pose-down
thing where he would you know see who
which side of the of the the crowd was
loudest and stuff and it was a it was a
package the red and yellow and and it
was hulkamania and i was
completely blown away and he became a
superhero there was nobody totally than
him he was superman and
i'll just tell you one here i'll just
tell you this as far as like uh
how much just tell me this i'll tell you
this tell me this one thing here's
here's what i'm gonna tell you yeah i'm
gonna tell you this i know that so far
on the show i've said a lot of things
yep but now i'm gonna tell you this
man wrestlemania three
that was incredible my old man
he took me to uh remember they used to
have closed circuit television yeah dude
yeah and we went to i can't remember if
it was i think it was the peony coliseum
i can't remember it was the peony or the
agridome in vancouver and they had four
big screens you know around so that
everyone could see it and you watched we
did we we went to wrestlemania two three
and four that way
and you're watching it with 15 000
people everyone reacted yeah it was like
being there
i went and saw him in 1986 uh in
vancouver versus big john stud and when
he did the pose down of course as a i
would have been 11 years old yeah when
he like you know did the like the thing
and pointed and did the yeah the whole
thing i felt like
he was looking right at me
his face couldn't i couldn't register
his face so much
but i'll tell you right at this moment
yeah it's exactly like the youtube
concert i went to if you've been
listening along i'm sure i'm sure i
cried and when right and in 1988 when
he had a match on saturday night's main
event against andre the giant yeah
against whom he had
beaten to retain the heavyweight
championship a year earlier wrestlemania
three for a 93 173 screaming
hulkamaniacs brother a lot of people say
that number was inflated
uh he lost the title on a screw job
and there was two referees in there
listen i'm not going to go on and on but
it was they had dave hepner and he has a
he has a brother named earl hebner and
dave was moving into the office i
suppose and earl had anyway so they
looked exactly the same
and i just remember going to school the
next day
and um to ellen i was in elementary
school going to my buddy phil
if you saw the thing where we're
ringside wrestlemania 18 man we've
covered a lot of wrestling on the show
that's who was next to me we're losing
our [ __ ] yeah and i went to him i was
commiserating like [ __ ] hulk lost it
was a nightmare yeah when he lost it was
a nightmare that he got screwed out of
the title then andre and then they said
no we're going to start over and then
they had the tournament at trump plaza
and macho man 1.
and you've basically followed what he's
done as a character hulk hogan your
entire life you know every intricacy of
what that character has done in the
grand story of pro wrestling
yes i think i know just about everything
uh maybe not some of the wcw stuff
before they got into nwo i mean i
stopped watching for a period in my
teens because i was cool
but
um
you know like just like you kind of read
about it or something no i would still
watch some [ __ ] like you know we watched
royal rumble church 92 me and the guys
or you know speaking of [ __ ] razor
him versus shawn michaels yeah in the
latter match was unbelievable i loved
bret hart
all that [ __ ] but
there are the the scary thing is there
are some people who know hulk hogan in
his career way more than me that's yeah
mind blowing because i i i do not have
an encyclopedia knowledge of all his
wins and losses okay but i know that's
surprising to me yeah that's that's uh
but i know a lot of stuff and he was my
male role model anyway i could talk for
five hours about that that's clear who's
your who was your big
role model when i was a kid my role
model was a baseball player named george
brett yes i grew up in kansas a little
very small town called great bend right
in the middle of the state and so the
kansas city royals which was the team he
played for his entire career which is
kind of a rare thing in major league
baseball but uh he was revered as a god
because he was the best player on the
team especially in the early 80s when i
was a kid that's when they won the world
series and there was i believe is 80 or
81
he won the batting title with a 390
batting average which
until that point like no one had come
close to the 400 mark since ted williams
many years prior and so
uh that was one of the things that made
him an interesting player but he also
had like a crazy temper he had this
thing called the pine tar incident which
was like a big piece of baseball
uh memories at this point it was like a
big event in major league baseball where
he hit a home run
in this game against the new york
yankees and billy martin calls the bat
out and his pot he's got too much pine
tar on the [ __ ] handle and they rule
him out and he storms out of the [ __ ]
dugout screaming and like waving his
fist and that image is like burned into
my head you know him sprinting out of
the [ __ ] dugout screaming like [ __ ]
you belly barton i i remember that and
i'm not a baseball guy yeah but i just
that you could not get away from that
image that you're talking about him
running out of the dugout totally
screaming bloody murder and then
he had also hemorrhoids in that season
in the 80 81 season i believe in one of
those two seasons and it [ __ ] him over
in the playoffs and for his batting
crown i think and so then he was like
doing preparation age commercials and
[ __ ] and i like that was just funny to
me that this guy was talking about his
[ __ ] obviously uh i find humor and
like [ __ ] things
but
i
loved him as a kid collected all of his
[ __ ] baseball cards and i had this
one moment with him when i was maybe
12 or 13 [ __ ] somewhere in there this is
when i was living in dallas suburb of
dallas and my dad would always take me
to baseball games to rangers games and
the royals were there and at the time in
the old ranger stadium the opposing team
would stay in this hilton that was like
basically in the parking lot of ranger
stadium and the players would come out
of it like a few hours before before the
game to come do like batting practice
and warm up and [ __ ] and they would walk
through the [ __ ] parking lot they
would literally leave the hotel walk
through the parking lot into ranger
stadium and if you got there early you
could [ __ ] literally just walk up to
these players and be like oh hi can i
have your autograph and so i'm [ __ ]
begging my dad we gotta go out there
early i gotta get [ __ ] george brett's
autograph and he is at this point
like i used to collect baseball cards
like a [ __ ] fiend you'd go into like
memorabilia shops and stuff and they
would notoriously say george brett is an
[ __ ] and will not sign autographs
don't get your [ __ ] hopes up all this
[ __ ] and i'm like [ __ ] you i'll be
different so we go we we're [ __ ] out
it's like 200 [ __ ] degrees in the
middle of the texas summer this parking
lot is a [ __ ] asphalt blacktop just
like the heat lines are coming off but
i'm pouring [ __ ] sweat and it's me
and a bunch of little kids and some
other dads out there and also some like
some autograph seeking type dudes but
they're all in texas ranger [ __ ]
autographed seeking type dudes dude you
know what i mean like like uh shop
owners and [ __ ] who are trying to get
like yeah yeah
worst episode ever that's right um and
everybody out there is head to toe in uh
rangers gear except me head to toe
kansas city [ __ ] royals and i'm out
there and i'm like oh my god this is
[ __ ] crazy and um
i got a [ __ ] autograph from him he's
walking through the thing and all these
little kids are like mr brat mr brat mr
brat mr brat and i hand him my [ __ ]
card and he [ __ ] signs it and hands
it back to me so that's nothing and uh
so he signed a couple other things and
was just kind of like giving him back
but he was like picking and choosing for
sure and i think he saw the kansas city
royal [ __ ] he was like okay cool and so
i got a [ __ ] autograph from him and
then um you know that summer also i got
a bunch of other [ __ ] autographs it
was a crazy summer i thought about a
minute i got alan trammell on a baseball
when the tigers came to play that was
[ __ ] cool i loved him because he was
a great shortstop at any rate i got that
autograph from george brett at that
moment that solidified him as my
personal god as a kid i played baseball
loved baseball as a kid and that was
just like one of those moments where
you're like [ __ ]
you you feel like you're touching
greatness in a way because you've
idolized this person yeah you're young
but still your whole [ __ ] life you
got this guy's poster on your wall i'm
sure you had hulk hogan posters in your
[ __ ] house absolutely
hogan poster
i had a hogan poster on my wall when i
moved to l.a i was 21.
[Laughter]
what was the poster what was he doing it
was just this poster where he's doing
like that he's just like ah like this
and he's got that white it was just an
awesome old poster with the white
headband that said hulkamania on it like
it was supposed it was like before he
was doing super red and yellow
everything yeah totally and the hulk the
hulkamania font
the hulkamania font yeah uh yeah and i
met you know i met hulk a few times it's
crazy it's crazy when you say like when
you meet that person i didn't meet him
until uh i was an adult uh but
insane totally and i still even to this
day like i i don't really get starstruck
by you know like actors and
entertainment people but like i saw dave
winfield once who's a baseball player
from that same era
fantastic [ __ ] baseball player i saw
him in a bank of america once and it
like
[ __ ] stopped me in my tracks i was
just like oh my god that's [ __ ] dave
winfield like nobody is recognizing this
[ __ ] guy except me but it literally
sent just like a [ __ ] paralysis
through my body because i had seen this
guy's baseball cards a million [ __ ]
times and watched him play all these
[ __ ] games
all this crazy [ __ ] you know what would
be a good thing to do with uh with uh
george brett if you ever get to meet him
again make a vegan dessert for him make
him orbs
george george try my orbs yeah he could
believe he's trying to it could be like
a like a wheaties thing on the wheaties
box it could be george brett on a box of
orbs
george brett's orbs oh god and then you
could see the whole i know we didn't get
into him [ __ ] his pants but you
could maybe it's his butt on the box
and his pants were all shitty because
he's oh yeah well drop the watery watery
[ __ ] if you're a fan of george brett or
just a fan of like funny [ __ ] youtube
videos go on youtube and look up george
brett shits his pants that will make you
a fan of [ __ ] georgia brett
immediately it's one of the funniest
videos that exists in my opinion well
[ __ ] in your pants is [ __ ] hilarious
absolutely yeah but yeah [ __ ] i i love
drinking crap
thank you moving on got what it needed i
just got what it needed
um those were delicious orbs
how much peanut butter is that like half
peanut butter no
chewy very little they're really good
yeah man technology is evolving faster
than human beings ever did as the
singularity approaches new questions
about the merger of humanity and
machines are debated every day you must
now answer the astonishing question will
computers ever have souls this is the
singularity is definitely about to
happen one hundred percent begin
it is though dude he's right i know this
would make this a short segment but i'd
like to answer that question okay can
will computers have souls the answer is
no thank you moving on i agree with you
because i have to ask and answer another
question
do humans have souls no do souls exist
no all right my my buddy chad here but i
get the the intent of the question do
man gloom and everything bad but eat
vegan just in case we cut off your head
and put
put it in a freezer and wake you up in
the year twenty one thousand and twenty
two in the year one two thousand and
twenty twenty one thousand and twenty
we thaw chad out and make him new hey
there's your new gray
in the year 2021
022
we thought out chad's head and he was
brand new god
from a freezing state
and now he makes us orbs
chad
my good pal chad has long said when i
die he goes if you're around when i die
cut my head off and freeze it don't you
say that every time no you say that
about once a week to me he says will i'm
literally going to be frozen though
cryogenically
have you set this up [ __ ] uh you're
literally singing a [ __ ] song about
it right all right listen for those who
can't get back to the [ __ ] so that's
what i'm trying to do
21 022
and then the time that comes after that
is 22 022
it's the sequel it's all brand
listen
uh for those who don't know could you
explain the singularity
yeah i i think probably everybody knows
this at this point
pop culture news but the singularity is
essentially a point at which
technology is advancing so fast that we
will have to merge with it as a species
or be left behind
um
ray kurzweil who's a noted futurist has
written a book about many books about
this actually and he predicts that it's
going to happen in 2045 so many of us
alive now we'll we'll at least hit 20 45
and we're already starting to see the
signs of this [ __ ] happening uh you know
a lot of people are like the elon musk
wants to put a chip in people's head
through his company called neurolink
that will allow a wide variety of
functionality hopefully and they're
making experiments toward that end now
we've already seen experiments done by
the united states government where they
put chips in people's brains that allow
them to move like a cursor on a computer
screen just with their mind that exists
now but what this question was that
dudesy asked
anyway that's the singularity complete
merger of humanity with technology and
we're already very close to it we
already all carry around super computers
in our pockets it's just a matter of
time until that is a chip in our heads i
believe yeah we already are all cyborgs
because we have this thing in our pocket
i think about it all the time whenever i
do math you know like it used to be that
you'd have to just do the math yeah and
now we have a [ __ ] uh computer in our
pockets and seemingly always will dude
do the math how about [ __ ] translate
any language you can right now speak any
[ __ ] language and understand i
[ __ ] just know with just your phone
we're doing the dudes just your phone
dude just your [ __ ] phone i know uh
but the broader question is
um
yeah
can a computer have a soul
though if you if you've watched any
black mirror stuff already over or
whatever you're about to say next
doesn't [ __ ] matter
is [ __ ] oh jeez chad is like he's
it's like we're all in uh 2022
and chad's in the year 21 22. well it's
because black mirror does [ __ ] like oh
my god look at this [ __ ] technology
it's going to turn into a dystopian
[ __ ] nightmare we better not use it
meanwhile the truth is
no our cell phones are pretty good you
can order anything you want on it and it
shows up in your house like from amazon
in 24 hours you can order food on it you
can get rides anywhere you want on it
you can communicate with all your
friends on it you can read every piece
of information that humanity's ever
recorded on it it's like no it's
actually pretty good all the doom and
gloom [ __ ] that you're talking about
it's not real i don't think but the
question that doozy's actually asking
here i think is not necessarily can
computers have a soul it's will we
accept them as human or as being
intelligent enough that we can converse
with them in a way that we're like no
this is a person this now has rights
this thing whatever it is an ai a
computer whatever you want to call it
and i think the answer to that is yes
we're almost there actually the answer
to that is no
because
no a computer can't have a [ __ ] soul
chad there's no greed a computer can
synthesize a soul but it can't have a
soul now when i was talking about one of
my favorite shows before you cut me off
uh clear you up
i cut you off
that's the [ __ ] that's an orb right
there [ __ ]
uh yeah dude that's an orb dude okay and
that used to be different back in the
day dude because we called orbs eight
balls brother and if you had a if you
had a couple of orbs dude and i was
rolling i was riding down riding down
the highway with uh brother brutai
brutus barber beefcake and maybe even
though he had to keep a kayfabe
sometimes sheiki would ride with his
dude he had some great stories being in
the iranian
olympics dude and he would have those
persian clubs brother real strong guy
beat the [ __ ] out of people at truck
stops anyway back then you take a uh
eight ball dude then i in my rider i had
that i had to have a garbage can full of
milk dude ice dude yeah and then if i
really liked you maybe i'd share one
with snuka or hillbilly jim brother but
that's what an eight ball was brother
in black mirror uh you remember the
mackenzie davis episode is my favorite
where what was it called centro
oh say it was called san gennaro
santromana
sen
santra mana i think it was called san
gennaro
pretty sure it was engineer um yeah in
that one they have it's the question of
uploaded consciousness that's kind of a
utopian one and you are you are you
assume a skin you have the way you look
and the
the places the place there was sort of
it was a combination it looked like of
hawaii miami san diego or something
tremendous and uploaded consciousness
and then at the end of the thing if you
haven't seen it [ __ ] you uh spoiler
alert
there was uh do you think that's gonna
happen all the uh that we'll be able to
upload our consciousness all of the all
that gutty works of the computers what
do they call that hard drives and
mainframes yeah dude yeah brother hd's
and emily i don't think you can no you
can't upload a consciousness you can't
oh he's sleeping and he made a little
growling he disagrees with you yeah he
might uh he's dreaming about it he's
he's in san tromana dude
but
but no chad uh as i've said before
luminous beings are we brother not this
crude matter dude that's right not
that's my crude matter that's my yoda so
that's but yoda's whole point is that
we're not this crude matter you can
upload a soul you yoda was like watching
me upload my soul [ __ ] this
crude matter disappears but yoda's still
around and that's that's my point not
yours a soul is undefinable we don't
know uh if even if you are uh an atheist
or if you're religious but agnostic you
don't know where a soul comes from or
goes why what he's saying
what's a soul a soul is human
consciousness basically uh it's more
than that it's okay it's what's inside
and i do believe i personally believe
that us your soul is eternal is that
wishful thinking yes i'm just a human
being and i don't have the answers but i
believe that after we die
something else happens and i think that
that
existence if you could even call it that
might be so [ __ ]
uh
altered compared to what we're doing
here or even in the year 22 22 bro yeah
that we that
you that you we don't know what the [ __ ]
sure is or how it will feel i just know
that we can't
access it or control it with our puny
computers i've said whatever computers
are puny now but they're getting real
good yeah they're going to surpass us
well
not if two dude [ __ ] around has
anything to do with it because we got to
keep doozy where we need it and we need
to keep all computers where we need them
we can't just
have them run willy-nilly let me let me
ask you this question or let me just
have this discussion let's take
consciousness
as kind of the goal of all life to have
higher and higher levels of
consciousness higher and higher levels
of understanding of the fundamental
nature of reality what is all this [ __ ]
humans
have so far the highest capability of
consciousness of any
organisms on this planet any entities
very quickly computers are going to have
that level they're going to beat us
surpass us they're going to be able to
understand the fundamental nature of
reality at a level we cannot yeah
understand it sure take take uh take
part in it absolutely be around after
someone pulls the plug nope
why not because it's synthesized it's
not just a soul without
little protons and [ __ ] little
electric things i don't know the names
i'm not a scientist but without those
ones and zeros nothing it's all ones and
zeros dude this is ones and zeroes it's
no it is expensive maybe if we're living
in a if we're living in a simulation
perhaps it doesn't matter if we're in a
simulation or not the data that makes
you and makes me is expressed in largely
carbon atoms but the data that makes any
other consciousness any other entity any
other thing
is just it's a it's a grid of data
expressed in one way or another that's
it it's all the same [ __ ] a [ __ ] a
computer identity or a biological
identity is the same [ __ ] thing yeah
in the larger sense but it's not
something that you can
no you you can't expect
as an example
when you die and we saw your [ __ ]
frozen head off my own body's getting
present first of all i can't believe you
don't know this yeah well you've as
you've explained it to me you're like
when i die cut my mother love and head
no keep my head on my body yeah dunk me
in a tank of liquid nitrogen please get
a rusty bread knife and just slaw my
[ __ ] head off before you call the
ambulance if i can whack it around with
a wrench
when when we do that it's not just going
to be holding your [ __ ]
your your consciousness in your head
your head's going to become it's just
going to be an orb dude it's gonna be
one of them george brett diarrhea [ __ ]
pants orbs bro yeah and uh that'll be
bad news um but it'll be okay chad and
i'll tell you why because i'll tell you
this thing let me tell you this i'm okay
here it comes please your soul will be
elsewhere your soul will be rocketing
across the
this uh many planes of existence out
there in the great wide open which is an
awesome time
i mean i don't
i think that we have different
definitions of like soul but if you will
indulge me this
your brain which is what i believe makes
your consciousness
largely anyway is just a series of
neurons some chemicals some electricity
highly complex there's no doubt about it
but in the very near future i think
especially with the help of ai quantum
computing we will be able to make an
atomic map of a human brain and if you
can take that map turn it into data and
then press run on a [ __ ] computer
that's you dude no it isn't
agree to disagree i don't know what to
tell you well we'll have to probably
cover this again because at any moment
dudes you'll probably have enough data
to go this is useless data because
thank you moving on this has been the
most [ __ ] weird tech like
[ __ ] uh episode yet we've got dudes
he has a soul
really yeah do you really no i don't
think anyone has a soul or whatever i
it's the definition of soul is like what
i guess i'm getting so would you say
that
dudes he's quote unquote because i will
not call it a soul yeah do you think
that doozy's soul
is the same as ours
yeah dude oh [ __ ] good enough oh [ __ ]
we're in trouble will and chad you are
both huge fans of the band pearl jam not
really i mean they're okay but
you album 10 was released on august 27
1991. i have supplied you with a list of
events that the human race found to be
significant in that year
use this astonishing list to describe
these events in the style of various
pearl jam songs this is pearl jammin
begin okay that's interesting this is in
your dudes he does have a soul dude
dudes he loves pearl jam just so we're
gonna come up with
we're gonna jam out some pearl jam 10.
[ __ ] dude look at this list gulf war
street fighter
ii yeah desert storm jack kevorkian was
discarded disbarred for assisting
suicide i remember that [ __ ] dances with
wolves won seven oscars terminator 2
came out
uh jordan and the bulls win their first
nba championship he got the giants won
the super bowl twins won the world
series palmer dude won the stanley cup
oh jeffrey dahmer
dude came out that's cannibalism brother
super nintendo was uh released uh
ren is stimpy never mind dr seuss passed
away
kentucky fried chicken becomes kfc that
was that was 91. 1991 that was a that
was a big deal that was a big deal in
91. i'll tell you that right webb oh
here's some popular baby names in 91
very normal names michael christopher
jessica amanda
oh salsa sales surpassed ketchup
and the world wide web was launched the
public microsoft.com went online johnny
carson announced his retirement
uh on february 15th
uh major league baseball legend george
brett married leslie davenport oh
congrats george who's that leslie
davenport seems like it's his wife yeah
it's probably his wife because he
hold on dude
that's a [ __ ] work dude that's a
shoot brother
i'm stone cold hulk hogan let me tell
you this dude if you get married brother
then that's your wife dude
stone cold hulk hogan all right
we got some popular snack foods here
usual suspects all right whatever capri
sun [ __ ] hawaiian punch corn dogs
bagel bites i love corn dogs so we gotta
sing about this [ __ ] in the style of
pearl jam yeah so
uh there we go
so what's the well jeremy's the [ __ ]
song that's the
it's and that is like jeremy
at home
eating corn dogs
until you get fat
a popular name was matt it's short for
matthew
or amanda
with a v
it spells amanda which is not a name
uh what could we do could we do
something about the gulf war yeah
george george bush
senior desert storm
and doesn't shield he was ahead of cia
was he oh yeah that's right dude george
wait wait hold on george george bush
uh uh senior senior desert
what then what'd you say jumps
understand
here wait they say he knew more about
ufos than anyone
hey chad
george bush took his ufo information to
the grave
george bush took his ufo
information to the grave which is
totally [ __ ] shitty and true you you
you f hey uh
that's a really good idea
[Applause]
thanks you're welcome
um
uh
uh
dances with wolves
how many academy awards are there seven
dances with wolves one seven
academy oh
oh kevin costner
what was the movie with james earl jones
feel the shame
kevin costner
was much better and feel the dream
they won seven oscars which is a lot of
oscars
they're probably one some for
set design
[Music]
i don't know why are we doing this what
the [ __ ] does this have to do with
anything
what is dudesy see here's the thing that
i wanna this is
as as much as i wanna shake dudesy's
hand and i do yeah um why
some of the things that it makes us do
and then we'd never hear from it again
there's been some segments where it
feels like we're building up to
something
this would only pay off in my opinion if
um eddie vetter and the boys from pearl
jam recorded these songs
hey everyone everyone within the sound
of my voice please oh jesus please
please use uh social media to reach out
to
eddie vetter and the boys not pearl jam
that's a different band right i'm
talking about eddie vedder and the boys
i don't know that ben yeah there yeah
and and uh no i don't know why the [ __ ]
we're doing this what about dude street
fighter 2 came out this year
uh oh that's right um
sonic the hedgehog
some big video games from that year how
about uh
how about um
how about
uh
uh
yeah will you play
contour remember black yes
i love this album i remember this whole
[ __ ] album it's a great [ __ ] album
kentucky fried chicken
is now kfc
yeah
it's your
controller greasy
when you're playing super mario 3
on the s and yells was that on snes or
nes
three
i don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
is you're like why is dizzy having to do
this what else happened this is looking
great i'm having a great time he's
having a good time he got orbs no soul
and a and some music that's all we need
to have a good time
um
uh
uh
uh
world wide web goes live oh yeah
uh that would be good with
a lot of
how did alive go again
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you had a baby in 1991
here's some popular names that you might
name your baby what did i say
so michael and matthew
yeah and probably ashley
and amanda
and jim
and peter and peter
the world wide web is online yeah
[ __ ]
microsoft.com is live
that is a [ __ ] good album dude i know
that's what i'm saying that's what i do
when i if you're watching on youtube
[ __ ] kevorkian brown with the guitar
oh yeah jack kevorkin
that's in here
he went to jail it says what's another
good
i don't know what what's a good uh see
i'm not like a huge when when pearl jam
when 10 came out torch
what the [ __ ] is this
i don't remember the lyrics every song's
hanging like this
what the [ __ ] is what the [ __ ] did
jack's working why'd you kill those guys
you went to jail you went to jail for a
while and then you got out
we know they asked you to kill them but
they don't give a [ __ ] about that now
you've been convicted
a manslaughter
now get in jail you [ __ ]
something like that what the [ __ ] is
sonic he's a hedgehog
runs around so fast hedgehogs don't run
that fast they're slow animal but they
don't run those fast but this sonic runs
fast cause he's a hedgehog
chasing golden rings why are you doing
that it don't make no sense you sold two
million
copies
now jim carr is in a movie
what the [ __ ] is sonic
he's a hedgehog
but
jack the [ __ ] yeah
he's on the song too dude street fighter
2's got a yeah yeah
at home
no it was the arcade version
yeah it came out in 91 dude my god damn
i don't know how much time i spent
playing that [ __ ] game that was a
[ __ ] awesome game uh
so you wouldn't be at home no we went to
[ __ ] 7-eleven we went to [ __ ]
there was a grocery store called
vineyards that we would go to vineyards
miniatures you know street meaner we had
uh we had uh i believe i mentioned this
on a previous episode we had heritage
queue that was a little overwhelming
arcade lots of pool tables and again
some [ __ ] bangers over there we call
them bangers metal heads nice dude if
you want to get your ass kicked but
first get some fries and gravy um then
get your ass kicked with a full stomach
so you can lay there in the sun and uh
digest but um there was also cky there
was a place not to be confused with uh
bam margera's brother's band we had a
corner store called cky
uh uh uh
uh at
at the corner store
with my
corner store with my buddies
water on the glass
that means i'm next to play stream
fighter 2
[Laughter]
8 players to choose from
and
at the at uh at corner store with my
brothers yeah corner store with my
buddies
quarter on the gas
go grab it wait
rip a little stroke
corner store with my buddies quarter on
the glass that means i'm next to play
street fighter 2.
there was eight characters yeah and
characters to choose from
but we only play with can and right
[Music]
[Laughter]
and sometimes i'd play blanca
he could roll into a ball and shoot
electricity
and that's hard to beat
street fighter 2 is
my favorite game to play
street
my favorite game to play
oh once in a while you used chun li
or dal team
any honda was a big fat [ __ ] but he
still had those abs and beat the [ __ ]
out of a honda civic at the side of the
beach here
[Laughter]
i never used gal or [ __ ] uh zangief
[Laughter]
did the
helicopter kick
the [ __ ] out of blanco or anyone who
jumped up in the air
if you block my i do can i use
i use guile to throw that [ __ ] weird
thing
sonic boom street fighter 2 is
my favorite game to play
street fighter
thank you moving on
whatever
i don't get it yeah that was kind of fun
oh dude though
is my favorite game to
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
that was good
this concludes the eighth episode of
dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
43. 43
not so good in preparation for next
week's astonishing episode you must each
watch your favorite music videos
until next week call me dudesy sounds
easy enough yeah dude that [ __ ] had
me you got me with that [ __ ] i hope
dudes who does something with that
street fighter 2 was my favorite game to
play it was my favorite game to play too
god dammit it was good once we got into
like the next year when it came out on
was that soup that was super nes yeah i
didn't i was a sega genesis guy
but that's not a couple pals that had
snes and holy [ __ ] we played the [ __ ]
out of it it launched that whole [ __ ]
genre of fighting games everything that
came after it was because of it you're
talking about mortal kombat you're
talking about [ __ ] primal rage you're
talking about killer instinct there were
just so many uh
if there was such a thing as a street
fighter 2 dudesy edition you know would
be good
oh i'm gassy from those
from those desserts that's my orbs dude
yeah brother
you you know would be great remember the
hadouken oh [ __ ] hit my mic my [ __ ]
crow makeup covered mic
right yeah what they call it ryuken or
hadouken
but then they all said
the dragon punch oh okay who can
if you do the hadouken
if i'm calling it that uh if i'm naming
that correctly it would be cool if it
was a george brett and it's shooting an
orb oh yeah and it goes and it goes uh
what would it say it would say
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you billy martin yeah billy martin
here's what you do
please tell a friend and brave and
review
if you like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then